μια επόμενεκλεκή διακριδικασια να ειστεδίπλα σαν παλαιότερο στέλεγχος να βρίσκει στε εκεί κύρ επιθα στην
πρώτη γράμμη γιατί το κόμμαθερώ ότι έχει ανάγκη τα παλαιότερα στελέχει όπως είπατε να δώσουμ
το πρόβλημα με μένας σαστοχοποι είναι η έλειψη χρόνου αλλά το κάνω το κάνω το
κάνω όσον μπορώ δε είμαι στην πρώτηγραμμή με την ανεια ότι ερφανίζομαι και λιπά στας
επιτροπές που εχουσιάξει αλλά επικινωνώ επικυρονό και προσπαθώ όταν δω κάτι στραβώ να τοπ άλιστα
επισυράνετων πρόεδρος βλέπω και τη ομόσπονδιάς εργοδοτών και βε μιχάνον ποια ισχέση το επιχειρματικού κόσμο
με την πολιτική και τους πολιτικύς σήμε οπιχρηματικός κόσμος πρέπει να διατηρή σχέσης με την
πολιτική κατάσταση και η εμοσκοδίεργο τώ και βαομιχάνων πρέπει να πω της οποίας είναικαι ο
μόνος επίτιμος πρόεδρος πάει πολύ καλά δηλαδή η άνθρωπι που είναι τώρααρκετάστη στην πρωτηγραμμή ο
γενικός ιθυντισο πρόεδρος και η αλλησυβουλη είναι πραγματικάαξι επαίρνων προσπαθούν όσον πορούν η όπως είπα
πρέπει πάντα να ταχής ως οτανί ε επιχειρηματίας και ανοίκη σε μια οπωσποδίαρδών να τα
έχεις κατά με τη πλιθική και της ποιδικος επιδή βλέποντας στοτα όσα κάνα κάνετε καταλαβαίνω
και ια